hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play don't starve
ok when we last left off we were just
starting adventure mode we're on the
second day of our first world which
means that we need to find Maxwell's
portals again and again four more times
before we reach the end and even I don't
know what lies at the end but it is
almost night time and I kind of forgot
that I started at nighttime but it
should be fine either way because I know
where I need to go now let's see there
we go done the blue cap if you if you if
you cooked up the blue cap that puts up
your health right fix it no bet did not
I'm stupid it just increases your sanity
I don't know what I'm doing in this game
so don't question me Oh anyway I got a
go the long way around actually I'm
already closer this way so I bet this
way goes around hang on I got this I got
it all under control guys don't worry
about me
I am a Advent professional more poop
yeah I picked up more poop never have I
been excited to pick up more fat a lot
of evil O's give me while I just grab
you boobie that is a lot of people hose
what the hell anyway wait my meter just
said I was getting closer again what's
up with that I'm not exactly sure why
did it suddenly I thought for sure it
was over there but maybe I'm maybe I was
wrong wait no that doesn't make any
sense why would it be cleaning um maybe
I have no idea how this thing works
where where do I go
Oh was that sound during it okay I'm
almost positive it has to be on the
other side of this thing but this is
looking more and more like very
stupidness
this is stupid I'm just keep going south
and I'm never gonna hit this it's never
gonna cross over because it's yeah oh no
I've gone the wrong way
okay I need to go back but it's almost
night so I'm not good
well I've done goofed and uh it's not
now so until then I just need to wait
out the night in the darkness build a
camp i Boosh hey cha what happens if you
put manure on a fire poof oh oh that's
horrible
yeah well beggars can't be choosers
alright we're gonna wait out the night
so see you in a bit
alright good morning everybody thank you
so much for waiting patiently we are on
our way up and out okay
so we got in a good situation when we
came into this portal area because
obviously there was that chest even if
it was winter we did pretty well because
we got on the Hat right away which
protected us from frostbite a bit which
I can actually take off and save just in
case there's of no way it won't matter
because I'll be dead anyway anyway I
don't need these B flows because
hopefully I can get out of here I'm
assuming that Maxwell's portals is in
that swampy area over there to the left
I just need to get around to the other
side which is my big problem because I
am stupid and kept heading south why
well because I'm stupid I just said that
weren't you paying attention I'm stupid
I must be getting pretty close I know
give me Bernie have you seen a portal it
looks evil in his maniacal in many
different ways
hey look at suspicious dirt but that
does not interest me or I am a gentleman
scholar Hey look at piece of me ah here
it is the bridge was right here if I did
just looked like for two sewo hahaha no
no got me now got it go get it I'm too
close you cannot kill me now I think
even if I if I do die whoa whoa whoa let
me get a spirit
case damn it carrots kind of give a
little bit of help
not much though I'll save a bit I don't
know if I could take another hit but
this thing is going wild which means the
portal is nearby I just got to find it
now my hair it must mean that that's
it's in this area I would assume I would
assume that it points to biomes that are
nearby the item in question it's got to
be very careful where I'm walking
there's spider webs everywhere and
there's those stupid tentacle monsters
oh no no no no oh wait I don't where is
it if it says it's over here where the
heck is it new me yeah I'm just gonna
get over to something it must be down to
the right here okay that's the only
other place it could be just gotta dodge
the tentacles oh no no no I won't be the
victim of your easy javanese what are
you oh what is that thing hey they
killed it
good good good what if they're fighting
my enemy and they Frost don't kill me
because we saw in the swamp you see that
Pigman house / go I don't want any Oh No
they killed the Pigman no well where the
thing is it where the thing is the thing
where the thing is the thing where thing
is the thing I don't know I don't know
it keeps blurring on and off where is it
oh where is it you say it's close it's
obviously not offering to the Beast what
Beast
I'm following the trail of pig heads Oh
well this ain't good when why was it
hang on it must be off to the right here
I don't know why it would say that it
was blaring up there if it wasn't
anywhere nearby I'm getting real far
from it now this isn't helping me I
don't know where to go I just got to
keep exploring this entire forest
because eventually I'll uncover it
hopefully maybe the signal is very faint
all right let's head back up it might be
in this area in the center here yeah I
do not like those things I can't take
many more than one hit from that I can't
take any more than one hit for anything
even probably those I don't want to mess
with those fish guys they don't look too
friendly ah I said I don't want him as
well I said I don't getting late no no
you need to you need to calm down
I must be getting pretty close oh no I
won't be able to see huh tentacles gotta
watch out gotta watch out ha ha ha ha
you're killing me you're killing a
whoohoo that was too close
I do think that if I die here I will
restart in the beginning of adventure
mode I'm pretty sure come on let me find
it before nightfall
I didn't a regulation no I am NOT this
is awful
no don't pick that that'll hurt you man
this is this is crud not walking into
you can barely see anything up no bond I
got it
there's too many of them they're
everywhere we're gonna murder me ah oh
oh oh man I had no idea where was that
wasn't helpful at all whoo interesting
that's so cool I started back at the
beginning of Maxwell's door before I
even started an adventure mode I mean if
if I die in the first chapter that's not
that bad
I was just Chuck my mistake was just
wandering around the swamp so what I'm
gonna do here is because I have all the
stuff I'm gonna make uh I need more wood
I'm gonna make a sort of permanent
campfire here so that I just have stuff
here so if I die again I'll be able to
go back but what I'm gonna do this time
I don't know if I'll be lucky enough to
get a Maxwell Maxwell's Muji whatsit or
whatever I'm king late no it's not or
I'm gonna make one anyway but no it's
not foosh right now I'm gonna go back in
Maxwell door oh yes I'm ready should i
dial just beuter bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye so I'm a bit of a slob today
I was busy this morning I've been
getting up earlier and earlier I'm just
a giant mess most of the time king of
winter winter is coming yes I am a fan
of Game of Thrones I really do like it
yah yah yah yah yah yah okay they give
me a divining rod and they gave me a
backpack this time with an ax blueprint
oh my goodness I was on fire
fire things on fire in the winter they
say keep me warm
okay I got multiple blueprints why do I
need oh this way I don't need a science
machine and I can learn it right away
cool all right so I got plenty of wood
plenty of things I need sticks and food
obviously in the beginning because I
need to survive this winter but it
shouldn't be too much of a problem
because I mean heck I got everything I
need right here
come here bird go for the eyes change
your mind halfway through you can't
hesitate when you need to kill you some
birds got strike when the striking is
good actually I had plenty of grass I
didn't really need you uh
can't move my bones I'm too cold need to
find out
just make it torture don't know why
don't just right-click on things
wait is that helping is this torch
helping weird better help if not I'm
just gonna build a campfire can't risk
taking damage because I got damage like
half of my health was gone because I
accidentally stuck through the winter
and just kind of stood there like a lot
a lot a lot nothing wrong with me yes
it's hard oh it's gone oh it's so cold
how do I go out I need to make Oh
Beefalo hat hahahaha a be full of that
man and you thought I smelled bad well
is that okay
enough making references other things
are dominant okay the day is long
however you just need to venture out a
bit I guess his torch doesn't really do
much I just need to find some food
that's what I need
there we go fairies I don't see any
carrots but at least there are some
berry bushes or am i there right
whatever oh oh now the torch is giving
me some heat is that what's happening
here nope no it's not
nevermind that was a lie picot tickets
have it so cold
No get back here look it's too cold
come on nipples freezing up by the fire
gonna log on it I got a log should bring
log you had logs
well they said bring lols I brought luck
I think the torch helps a little bit but
not much
gimme gimme me all of it I know it's so
cold tough it out you're almost back
pine guns will be good fuel is Comiskey
this is not gonna go well I just need
enough to survive a night because as
before I'm hoping that winter will just
be one night although I don't know if
that's guaranteed to be true there's a
heat stone it's warm and cuddly for a
rock can I put that and wear that on my
head what do I do with that
oh do I drop it and then it'll know it
won't
okay so I'm guessing that just heats me
up a little bit as I'm walking around
I've I don't know I don't know how this
works is all mystery to me guards all
right what am i doing done you do I need
to stop messing around and be serious
for a little bit who'da me be curious
hilarious hey don't tell me what they do
there's a fire right there
you put something on the fire before it
goes out I don't know what how about a
bird can we put a bird on the fire I'll
put all the birds on the fire burn all
the birds I'll burn this damn forest
down the forest was burning a little bit
there ah why did I have to die it was it
was almost impossible to see the
tentacle creatures in the swamp at night
and that was my stupidest stupidest move
I could have ever possibly made
wandering around with swamps at night is
a bad idea don't do it okay all right
everybody I still got plenty of evening
so I got a venture out um what I'm
probably gonna do is what I'm probably
gonna have to do is I'm just gonna make
a series of campfires by resources and
then I'll be able to quickly chop down
these wood and get some more materials
so that I can keep moving forward which
is the most important thing because time
is of the essence so longer I spend here
the less chance I have of surviving
obviously unlike Bear Grylls of the
woods
wait I already made that joke we're the
one where I'm like Bear Grylls but I
came during my I don't bring my own piss
well it's about time that came to that
time to break up the pissed glasses and
drink me down some No
disgusting but that is true in a
survival situation it's better to do
that instead of drinking nothing I guess
don't drink it don't do it
99% of you are never gonna be in a
survival situation that requires you to
drink their own pee so in the general
sense don't do it as my general piece of
advice to you do not do it bad for you
bad in general most Flint
give me a flea tea could I get an
interview plenty here we go here's and
then my next step right cheer Boosh I'm
so amazing I have made [ __ ] not really
amazing considering what I've done
already in this game but I'm trying to
survive no chop it my stupid mouth like
clicks randomly I don't know why it just
randomly will click wherever the hell it
wants whenever the hell at once doesn't
matter what I want or what I need
my needs are irrelevant compared to what
my thing wants to do stack that tray
where's the tree monster uh uh huh
where's your big tree guardian now I
hope you all out oh my my access proves
well perfect timing though by her riff
let's make another one chopper chopper
we got enough for another axe too so
let's make our way quickly to the next
checkpoint before we get caught in the
blizzard here I'm hoping to find another
berry bush but looks like that's not
gonna be the case oh oh no those have
been picked clean by me question mark or
or do they have berries in them these
are new berry bushes why ever why in the
world are they picked clean
I've been out I did not pick these berry
bushes what are you doing are you doing
I don't have enough berries I need more
food but I cannot kill those damn Birds
whatever I since time is of the essence
I am going to be traveling during the
night let's see just eat him up
actually let me cook them I think they
give a little more food and a little bit
of help if I cook them yeah they do give
a little bit of health if I cook him in
much more food so that was dumb of me
not to cook that in the beginning but
anyway so let's move forward into the
night brave reason you right-click to
make it easier I don't know why I wasn't
doing that in the beginning all right
what I'm trying to find is a suitable
place to set up a new camp and then keep
moving checkpoint style forward until I
can get out of here in it I can't find
anything
have enough to make plenty of torches
and so far the cold hasn't really been
affecting me all that much so I don't
really know what the deal is there
hopefully it'll just stay like that like
I don't know if winners about to end
after this one I hope so and that's why
it's not really affecting me but I don't
know enough about this game to make that
call
hello bees please do not kill me I would
rather survive if it's all right with
you
nothing nothing nothing a whole lot of
nothing very much Shh thank you
sticks berry bushes I got plenty of logs
so right now I'm just trying to explore
Wow uh anything anything at all
anything and it's day but it is still
winter we're in for a bit of trouble but
at least we have a lot of daytime I mean
that's what I really appreciate it okay
pick that up go I buried I don't want
you anymore you can't be in my life
anymore
ooh can I burn this whole forest down
I'm gonna burn this forest down I'll
just clear some way urn you [ __ ] burn
how do I burn you do I just create a
fire near them and then just load it up
with wood the best way
it's out of control ah it's out of
control
hey I will be warm now ha ha ha take
that tree monster ha ha ha ha ha evil
villains always do this ha ha ha ha ha I
don't know why I don't know what this
does ha ha ha I was blame God of War 3
um because I just I was playing through
the God of War series recently and when
that unit you know if you played it you
know when that scene when the guy
betrays the guy and you're like oh no I
don't know my car Cole hang on I wasn't
acting system I need to get that
charcoal before it blows away no not the
Evergreen Kristen no get that damn ah
Bob don't touch it that no get uh oh
you're so stupid
you're don't do bad oh you're so dumb
you're so dumb you as they would right
in front of your face and you just let
it blow in the wind you're so dumb all
right whatever
now that I've successfully become an
eco-terrorist hello monster meat I've
killed a monster while I was in here
how's this carry on I can't I can't
click on anything cuz there's too many
burnt-out husks of trees all right
whatever
there's a road here and so far the cold
has not been affecting me all that much
don't know why maybe my heat stone that
must be it I don't know how I activated
it but I did well I'm just too pro for
my own goods these woods are dense what
am i doing how am i doing on the
divining rod
no really I know that's a lie because it
was a lie before I must be getting
pretty close yeah right shove it up your
bum
I'm headed in the right direction now
this doesn't know anything about what
it's doing it is a liar a dirty dirty
liar I'm just going into the woods now
time to die good I don't want to live
like this anymore I don't wanna I don't
want to live in this world I can't take
it the stress is just too much on my
fragile psyche
all right I'm tougher than that my name
is markiplier and I'm Way too tough for
that can you fish out of those ponds
that's just what I'm curious about see
what I don't understand is it like is it
just wait it might make more sense if
it's not a proximity thing but a
directional thing like yeah that must be
what it's about because it's got to be
direction it's a divining rod oh I'm so
stupid you guys were probably yelling at
me it's not a oh that's why in different
areas it seemed like it was getting me
closer so in that direction okay no see
as soon as I turned it suddenly got so
if I go like if I'm pointed this way my
theory is correct
now oh well maybe it is just not working
right because I was hitting the wall
there but either way that means it's got
to be down there I don't know how to get
there though
whoa see see see see it's more of a
directional thing than a actual thingy
thing see I'm pointed in this direction
so I just got to keep going in one
direction once it says that I'm getting
pretty close right this thing's going
crazy so I might be right on target stay
on target
stay on target okay so on oh that's not
a good thing that's not a good fine
let's make a campfire right by the trees
again yeah burn it all down okay so
anyway um you guys see that I'm in a
fairly good situation for what I am now
so I will cut it here and we'll pick
this up later and now that I know how
the divining rod really works maybe
correct me if I'm wrong but now that I
know how the divining rod generally
works I can get out of here so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos and I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
ah
pop
Oh
I don't like this at all
you